le sénat le 23 juillet 2020 grâce à
maman demande ça a été dit de marie
mercier à la loi sur les violences
conjugales a été ajouté un
la possibilité pour le csa de poursuivre
les sites puisque depuis plus de 20 ans
il ya une loi qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas respectée en fait là faut savoir que
la plupart des sites sont souvent dans
l'illégalité la plus totale un retrait
de refus des vidéos évasion fiscale
retrait enfin donc les injonctions à
respecter la loi concernant l'âge des
mineurs il sent entre nous il s'en fiche
et donc le csa a donc depuis 20 ans
existe une loi qui interdit de
l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie parce que l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie est
complètement incompatible aujourd'hui
avec l'objectif d'une éducation sexuelle
qui impliquerait l'éducation
consentement l'éducation à la dezir et
aux rencontres entre deux personnes qui
désirent un acte sexuel on est vraiment
sûr dans la pornographie sur
l'érotisation de la violence et donc
pour le csa donc cette fois n'était pas
appliquée depuis 20 ans et maintenant le
csa a pour mandat de bloquer les sites
qui refusent de vérifier l'âge alors
effectivement cinq sites ont été mises
en demeure le 13 décembre
la devise avec un jour pour pour
s'exécuter alors les sites s'en foutent
complètement excusez moi du terme x
vidéo par exemple qui est l'autre grande
plateforme comme portneuf a même mis un
tuto pour avec un vpn contrer toute
tentative de blocage des sites donc ils
n'ont aucune intention de collaborer sur
quoi que ce soit une vidéo par exemple
est basée en république tchèque leur pdg
c'est les frères pas causé deux frères
français qui habitent en france
d'ailleurs tranquillement mais leur
argent et entre tchéquie paradis fiscaux
et les frères pas qu on me sur leur site
un mode d'emploi pour contourner un
éventuel blocage du csa d'accord donc on
en est là donc j'espère que ça va avoir
de la détermination pour faire respecter
au moins à minima cette première
interdiction d'exposition aux mineurs et
osez le féminisme a fait 7 alors le csa
avait fait avait été saisie par des
associations de protection de l'enfance
sur huit sites cinq ont été mises en
demeure osez le féminisme au mois de
décembre a fait une saisie du csa sur
118 sites c'est à dire à peu près
l'intégralité des sites pornos
accessible en france au nom de 118 et
nous avons saisi le csa pour leur
demander également de faire appliquer la
loi et de mettre un contrôle d'âge sur
les mineurs de façon urgente et de
réagir et simplement de ils ont la
possibilité aujourd'hui de saisir la
justice est d'ordre de faire de
d'ordonner le blocage des sites qui ne
mettrait pas en place des contrôles
d'âge pour ne pas exposer les enfants à
ces scènes de torture